[Music]
so i really like when florida man does
[ __ ] but this time it's an asian florida
man which is true
is that a new superhero don't look at
what he did but just look at how he
looks dude he looks like my friend nate
foo
[Laughter]
that's him
but nate has more cuter eyes i like
putting the first and last name of
somebody and then it's like hearing that
they raped and killed some children
i hope not because this guy looks like
evil nate food yeah he looks like his
eyes look weird oh it's safe because he
has dead eyes good name fluid has cute
little big old eyes yes this one has a
mole that really looks like neat foo
like if you squint you're if you squint
your eyes yeah but his eyes his eyes
look like evil like he's done some [ __ ]
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's pretty handsome
dude if steve was here you could squint
his eyes and think that look like all of
us
that's true he's really good-looking
you want to [ __ ] him or whatever he's
kind of dude
yeah 21 whoo
and he's a really romantic guy let me
tell you what he did he is romantic
i pick him good
he's gonna describe his final moments
with his wife oh no this is gonna be bad
when he was holding her hand
as she was laying in the tub listening
to her favorite song as she passed away
oh why in the tub after dying of stab
wounds he gave her for burning up his
passport oh what oh cause he was gonna
go cheat on her and then she was like
yeah ain't leaving she burned her past
did some unknown uh infidelity action
which led to her being angry and burning
up his passport so he stabbed her to
death put her in the tub
played her favorite song and held her
hand and she died
she he felt bad at the last minute
it's a bad day for the chinese i know
i'm surprised that he got two girls
shitty [ __ ] chinese articles
why can't they be i don't know
vietnamese
just mix it up
because you look like vietnamese yeah
see we should just do a math korea day
nobody's gonna complain about that here
listen vietnam just got
about that electricity
still florida man though he's still
florida man right but mathematically
just probability wise there's a billion
plus that's only counting the chinese
and china what about the chinese all
over the world man god damn that is a
huge probability oh my god chinese [ __ ]
you guys you guys want to hear it
there's a really interesting quote from
him and you'll go to town on this [ __ ]
he was asked why he didn't stop himself
from doing it and uh yang said because
that's not how i was raised
i don't stop he said
don't stop one stop
asian work ethic is the best
the follow through whether we're
murderers
serial killers it doesn't [ __ ]
he said he said he's the type of person
who goes all the way
committed
i never stop i finish first nevertheless
first place valedictorian burning a
passport not that big of a deal dude not
that big of a deal not that big of a
deal he has to wait two weeks every time
that's like really great at company you
know good work ethic it just went the
other way too i never understood maybe
it's from my perspective of this guy's
to me i think he's a pretty attractive
looking guy from his face it's like you
got the you're drunk bro
yeah why do this
why do this you had your whole life
ahead you get you get hired for jobs
faster when you're better looking right
you get [ __ ]
right yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah he had two
oh he had two [ __ ]
yeah so what's the problem here guy
life's good yeah so she burned his
passport that's not that big of a deal
though i forgot the wife was vietnamese
oh she probably went off on him
she was [ __ ] yelling at his ass there
you go that's the [ __ ] was like
i've been waiting
[Laughter]
there it is i got a trip to spain
tomorrow on this big game doom may you
have the [ __ ] uh [ __ ] trip
man john i don't give a [ __ ] beat that
[ __ ] boom done oh [ __ ] your
passport huh yeah
and he's like i don't understand the one
thing you say
[Laughter]
one thing but
his english is bad why don't you try to
speed up english
we had the communication problem
they're in therapy
it sucks too because this is one of
those cases where i mean i feel like all
of them are like this but he was
previously arrested for domestic
violence already
but they just [ __ ] beat her up before
or a different way
the other one i'm going to fall in the
vietnamese lady yeah
it's the same same wife
we are what we call victim blamers in
this room yeah you know what i mean what
if
she she could have asked oh [ __ ]
you gotta kill me if you want to go
there and he's like oh fine i'll kill
you oh what if huh i was like why don't
you kill me i triple dog dates
i want triple
you know me i'm chinese i like to gamble
fun
but there's still no nothing at stake
it's just a dare yeah it's just a dare
he wins nothing
there's nothing to win
challenge me [ __ ]
dog you're telling me that i can't get
away with this murder you'll see
never say she's dead in the bathtub
where's my money
hey
hello
i didn't think this one through
dogs
wait did they did they ask you about the
bathtub and the music and the oh yeah
what's the song yeah what's the song of
it was it was it trans hot little john
graduation vitamin c
it's called too close by next oh next
i'm just kidding i'm scared
of the weirdest [ __ ] song i'm like
they're too young for that [ __ ]
no yeah they're too young for that [ __ ]
it doesn't say what the song [ __ ]
justin bieber baby dog oh my god that's
a terrible it's usher confessions do you
guys have a couple song
why are you looking at me like you guys
huh because you're the romantic one yeah
yeah
you're the sexy dude you're a [ __ ]
kite flyer what the [ __ ] we got to talk
about just right after a [ __ ] murder
like how am i gonna associate my
couple's song with this [ __ ] no i just
wanna know something i feel like you
would have a couple songs not everyone
here you are the gayest
i wasn't even thinking that i wasn't
you're the most romantic
what's your song
we're not going there after a [ __ ]
murder [ __ ] you guys honestly all the i
know what it is you guys are all [ __ ]
ed sheeran's song
i'm not really i'm not bringing in the
truth of my romance into this [ __ ]
story we can do it on otr [ __ ] you guys
we don't have a song yeah we [ __ ] the
silence
if she ever says anything about i get
mad yeah it feels good
[Laughter]
she's like oh [ __ ] that's also how i
come too that's all i got
the freaking veins
i'm kidding we don't have sex
i'm a virgin but that's how you come
though
one by one
seven years together no sex whatsoever
after david is fully married then it's
on and we're gonna hear those stories
yeah we're gonna hear the song because
it's very christian like after that you
could be as horny as you want
good for you i always wondered too like
if muriel would treat me differently if
i had a six-pack
do you think why yeah well do you want
to hear the answer let's find out the
answer well you had a six-pack
definitely i've literally heard my girl
literally say if i had a six-time we'd
have more sex
the funniest and most terrible and
depressing thing ever
i [ __ ] love it so when she said that
you were like
i'm going to remember that it's that
without the laugh in between
so funny though
girls will do that though they'll say
like
these random [ __ ] up things yeah like
it's nothing like you know what if you
had a six-pack we probably have more sex
what do you want to eat
god forbid you say anything chicken
breast [ __ ] now
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i'm not yeah did she say that like as a
joke or no she was serious no she has no
sense of humor
yeah in what context like what happened
were you like let's focus on the artist
how come i'm not getting [ __ ] blow
jobs like i used to did you prompt her
with a question that's what i did
how come i'm not getting [ __ ] like i
used to
or was she like well maybe if you have
some [ __ ] ass yeah
not you're just somebody that i used to
that's your song you [ __ ] don't bring
my history into this the first shot in
that conversation then hey can we focus
on that set yourself up
how about this is so much more juice i
love it i love it the truth is it is
what it is you know like i i was a
little bit like hey
how come i don't get
[Laughter]
you asked the question and you didn't
want the answer and you got the answer
and it wrecked you a little bit and you
know what i didn't want the answer yeah
that's the point in the beginning why'd
you give me the answer when i didn't
want it exactly so what happened she
[ __ ] up yes
she will give you the answer and after
that you know what i said there i was
like
i need to go get a six-pack
and then you gain weight
and then i gain weight in order to start
to get lean packaged by barbell brigade
you